[Music]
it's summer 2018.
i'm sitting at my desk and one of my
clients walks in
he drops his bag on the floor and turns
to the others in the office asking what
they think of the latest headline about
brett kavanaugh's nomination to the
supreme court
as the 10 men around me casually debate
whether he had actually assaulted dr
blasey ford
i feel my chest heightened
i see them speaking but their voices
drop off and i can't hear anything
i stumble to the bathroom in search of
privacy
as the memories begin to flood my brain
i bury my face my palms i can't stop
them
suddenly someone walks in the bathroom
and the noise is enough to jolt me back
into the present
i take a deep shaky breath and walk back
to my desk as if nothing happened
these episodes continued and became
unbearable
i knew i needed help and finally made an
appointment with a therapist who would
change my life
she helped me see that these were ptsd
like flashbacks common among trauma
survivors
i had thought these were work-related
anxiety attacks
i had no idea and i hadn't even realized
that my client's comments were
triggering flashbacks to my own
experience with sexual assault an
experience i'd suppressed for years
now rearing its head
it was clear i would need to make time
for consistent regular therapy to
address these flashbacks and their
underlying cause
unfortunately the only time available in
my therapist practice was tuesday
mornings at 9 30 a.m
right in the middle of the weekly update
to our clients that i usually led
i dreaded bringing this up with my boss
i didn't want him to think i was weak by
disclosing that i was dealing with a
mental health issue
i decided to frame it vaguely around a
medical issue
surely he'd understand that
i approached him one day on our way out
of work
stumbling over my words as i tried to
blurt them out as quickly as possible
i need to see a doctor weekly for
treatment and the only time available is
tuesdays at 9 30 am
i know that conflicts with our weekly
client meetings but this is a priority
for me and i'm hoping you can help me
he looked concerned
is this a serious medical issue would
extended medical leave be a better
option
oh no
now he actually thought i had a serious
medical condition
i decided to backtrack and tell him the
truth
no no it's nothing serious well
it is serious
i'm going through a tough time and i
need to see a therapist weekly
he nodded slowly
are there any other days of the week you
could see your therapist
could you see them before or after
working hours
i shook my head no this is the only time
available
maybe you could go every other week
no i need to see this person every week
that's non-negotiable
looked at me for a beat and i saw
something shift in his face
you know what
do what you have to do we'll make it
work
as i reflect back on this experience it
makes me sad to realize that the only
way i thought my mental health would be
taken seriously was to claim a physical
illness
if in 2018 i'd torn my acl and needed
physical therapy i would have had no
problem going to my boss
so why did it feel so much harder to
share my mental health needs
one year later i myself was leading a
team on a high profile high stress
project with one of our largest clients
and i could tell something was wrong
one of the associates on my team we'll
call her rachel usually very focused and
high performing seemed distracted
i checked in with her one-on-one and she
shared that she was struggling with
depression but unable to consistently
see her therapist because of our travel
schedules
as consultants we typically traveled to
be on-site at our client monday to
thursday spending three nights on the
road
my heart ached for rachel when she told
me this
i thought back to my moment of crisis
year earlier and i wanted to help her
get the support she needed
but again i was nervous to bring it up
with my boss
i was concerned he might think that i
and the team couldn't handle the
pressures of the job which we'd signed
up for knowing involved travel
and i was up for a promotion and i was
worried my manager might doubt my
leadership abilities if i didn't tell
rachel no we have to be there this is
what the client wants
but i wasn't willing to tell her no i
wanted to help her get the support she
needed i knew firsthand the impact that
an hour a week with my therapist had
made on my mental health and i wanted
the same for her
i set up time with my boss and i told
him the team wanted to reduce our number
of days on the road
he initially pushed back saying the
clients aren't paying us to sit at home
but eventually after i emphasized the
physical and mental toll this was taking
on the team he agreed to try out a
three-day week travel schedule
the team stuck with it and rachel was
able to see her therapist every thursday
now
i don't claim to be the model of
effective management after all this was
before my mba
but the impact that my personal
experience had had on me allowed me to
empathize with rachel and help her get
the support she needs
i recognize not every work environment
will be this flexible but in the white
collar salaried work environments many
of us will go into after we graduate
why is it so hard to imagine a work
environment where employees can
prioritize their mental health even if
it's just an hour a week for therapy
my view is that making space for mental
health at work is hard because the
stigma around mental health still exists
80 percent of employees reported stigma
at the in the workplace about mental
health in a recent survey from april
2021
which is astounding when you realize
that in reality 20 of american adults
struggle with mental illness
let that sink in
one in five american adults you walk by
on the street see in the grocery store
and who are even sitting in this room
are struggling with their mental health
on a daily basis
and to make matters worse less than half
of those people get the treatment or
support they need
to put it into context one in five
americans has been diagnosed with
covid19 to date the same prevalence as
mental illness
mental health is the pandemic we're not
talking about
our deep prioritization of mental health
isn't a new challenge
however
we have structurally valued mental
health to a lesser degree than physical
health
mental health benefits are less likely
to be covered by health insurance plans
and are reimbursed at lower rates when
they are
the number of federally funded residency
positions in psychiatry has remained
flat since the 1990s even as the
population has grown
and demand for mental health services
has soared
these are just a few of the systemic
barriers preventing access to mental
affordable mental health services
today i want to focus on what we all can
do in our everyday lives to break down
the stigma around mental health and help
people take that first step towards
seeking care
i believe we can accomplish this by
shifting our perspective around mental
health to be equally as important as our
physical health
prevention trauma and recovery exist in
both realms
why should we think differently of
either
we can start by normalizing mental
health at home in our private lives and
in conversations with friends and family
and also in our public lives at work
it's at work where i see the greatest
potential for a shift in stigma around
mental health
now much has been written about what
corporations can do at an organizational
level to support employee mental health
i want to focus on what we all can do in
our everyday interactions at work to
support those struggling with mental
health
we can start by checking in on our
people and asking those on our teams
what they need to be at their best
hear your employees and respect their
needs without judging whether their
needs are worth investing time into
therapy
ask yourself if an employee or colleague
of yours needed physical therapy would
you respond differently
and don't underestimate your role in
creating a supportive work environment
through small changes to your daily
schedule
i challenge you to ask these questions
of yourselves to better support those
struggling with mental health at work
can you be the one to role model what it
looks like to make space for mental
health at work
it might make a world of a difference to
someone on your team
as it did for me
i still see a psychologist
every week four years later
and i am still working through the
effects of the trauma i experienced
but the impact of managers who respected
the boundaries i said at work cannot be
overstated
they took my mental health seriously and
respected my needs when i made them
known
my team was fine without being at that
weekly client meeting
all i needed was a compassionate manager
who was willing to step in for me
i challenge you to be that compassionate
manager for those on your teams and in
your workplace
thank you
[Music]